welcome to what's new in and not the
real name but we can't talk about all of
the new features added in this version
of Android for example marshmallow
brought you doze and app standby and now
in is bring you doze again but it's so
much more the goal here is to coalesce
background activity whenever the screen
is off and not necessarily when the
device is stationary so this brings doze
out of the tablet on a shelf model and
into the user out and about who needs
her battery scenario so shortly after
the screen is turned off doze will be
activated and all network access and
background jobs will be restricted into
maintenance windows that happen every in
minutes but in this lightweight mode
alarms wakelocks and Wi-Fi scans will
all happen normally and all of the other
does best practices still apply cloud
messaging of course this is all an
extension of doze mode so if the device
is stationary then the marshmallow
flavored doze will kick in you're
actually using your device it's also a
ton of cool new features like two apps
on screen at the same time that's right
phones and tablets will support split
screen windows where two apps are placed
right up next to one another
now this doesn't change the usual
activity lifecycle though there's still
only one app that's resumed at a time
the other app will be paused but not
stopped so it should be able to update
with new messages and keep a video
playing for instance there's a new
resizable activity attribute you add to
your manifest sentry to control how
you'll work with multi window mode and
also attributes for setting a minimum
size it's also a fancy new launch
adjacent intent flag to hint that you'd
like the launched activity to be opened
alongside the current activity and
there's a little something extra for
Android TV users picture-in-picture now
your app can continue to run in
miniature form on top of everything else
of course that means you should hide
things that are totally unreadable in
picture-in-picture there's new callbacks
for when you enter and leave this mode
if you choose to support it which you
should particularly for video apps out
there so yeah multi window wins the day
but there are so many new features that
have nothing to do with the UI like data
saver which was introduced
per app basis a while back so that the
user can specify certain apps to be
Wi-Fi only and keep their data costs
down but within we added a device wide
option this means your app really needs
to be good at not wasting data and I'm
not failing gracefully if you cannot
access the network right now so to help
you we added an API call so that you can
check if your app is network restricted
and maybe try a header to let the user
know your app isn't saved data mode one
of the most noticeable things in Android
n particularly for end users is going to
be the total visual redesign of
notifications yep all the standard
templates have changed quite
significantly
you also notice some of the features
from Android wear are being expanded
upon and making their way onto other
Android devices for example you'll be
able to use remote input to send replies
directly from the notification shade you
also be able to show the sent message
history in the notification so you
always know exactly where you left the
conversation now grouping notifications
make it a lot easier to head handle
multiple notifications from the same app
by creating a single summary
notification not allowing users to
expand it into individual actionable and
dismissible notifications grouping is
enabled by default on all apps but
you'll want that customize summary
notification to make for a great
notification experience speaking of
making things great for users encrypting
your phone is a great and secure and
awesome but it does mean that you have
to be around to help it boot up so if
your phone restarts while you're
sleeping your alarm clock has died as
well direct boot will allow the device
to fully wake up to have alarms and to
receive calls this way users won't be
stuck in a lurch and then they can put
in their password when they go to use
their device but it also means that if
your app handles calls or SMS messages
uses talkback or triggers an alarm you
will now need to be crypto aware which
means stated in your manifest when
targeting in and you will need to
specify which files should be device
encrypted or credential encrypted so
that you can receive special treatment
and speaking of special treatment
marshmallow bot permissions requests to
the user
in context with runtime permissions but
for storage taking it a step farther
instead of having to request access to
everything apps can now request access
to a specific folder such as alarms or
pictures with full support for both
internal and removable media volumes
also heads up some of your implicit
broadcasts are changing as part of our
continued focus on projects felt we want
to make background activity even more
efficient so all apps targeting me in
that listen for connectivity action
broadcasts and their manifest and rely
on that to launch their process will no
longer be woken because a single
networks which can result in bazillion
apps all waking up when maybe two of
them will actually do something and this
is horrible for performance and the time
has come to fix it because perf matters
however if your app is already running
it can still receive this broadcast with
context register receiver but as of in+
you will no longer be able to send or
receive a new picture or new video
broadcast
instead job schedule has been extended
to trigger jobs on a content provider
update which is a much better way to
handle a response to a picture being
taken and which means users won't wonder
why the camera app keeps freezing time
to migrate to job scheduler but if
you're still afraid of job scheduler
just tweet me we can check and Royden
also allows users to specify multiple
locales in settings which means apps can
now serve search results in multiple
languages or avoid offering translations
for languages that the user our honey
knows so the full list of locales for
user can be accessed via locale list get
default so check out the links in the
description for everything I mean
everything you need to know about
Android not the real name
[Music]